en novembre dernier internet se soulever
contre les images insupportables de
l'agression de michel est clair
producteur de musique qui suite à un
contrôle de police dans le xviie
arrondissement de paris se trouvait au
coeur d'une présumée bavure policière
qu'est ce qui se passe du mode tabac
soit là où sa voix sort des images
diffusées par le journaliste david
perrotin sur l'outsider qui expliquait
les circonstances de cette
interpellation en indiquant que michel
n'avait juste pas porter son masque dans
la rue une interpellation sur laquelle
michel était revenu sur notre plateau
dans la vie jamais je n'avais que
quelque chose comme ça en fait je me
suis christiane monde co mais
aujourd'hui un policier prend la parole
pour dénoncer ces images et s'exprimer
au nom de ses collègues impliqués dans
cette affaire
dans une vidéo intitulée touche pas à
mon flic bruno at elle explique que la
vidéo aurait été trafiqués passage coupé
images accélérées titre mensonger
nous travaillerons que dans un seul but
la vérité rien de plus que la recherche
de la vérité sans concession alors selon
vous les images de l'agression de michel
eyquem vont-elles été manipulé ou non at
elle est avec nous ce soir pour tout
nous dire sur sa version des faits merci
bruno attaque d'être avec nous merci
beaucoup vous êtes membre du syndicat
france police policiers en colère et on
va revenir sur les trois vidéos un conte
à découper et on va vous montrer bien
entendu chez vous ce soir en direct à
20h14 et yano à manoir ancien
fonctionnaire de police et qui vient
très souvent nous voir
vous savez il paye le loyer tous les
mois avec mercy noam ça va bien deux
hommes ça va très bien merci
alors je vais d'abord m'adresser à bruno
bruno faisait donc policiers membres du
syndicat france police policiers en
colère et vous êtes l'auteur donc de
cette vidéo qui fait énormément parler
dans cette vidéo vous dites que cette
vidéo a été manipulé et que les images
de l'agression michel est clair pour
vous il n'y a pas eu de violences
policières
déjà vous vous avez voulu analyser les
images très vite pourquoi parce que vous
êtes dit je veux savoir la vérité
mais c'est exactement ça c'est à dire
que vous ici vous avez tous vérité vous
avez défendu deux éclairs mais t on
exactement on a été touché par le
témoignage de mia je veux lire
comprendre que c'est l'empathie parce
que moi aussi j'ai été touché comme vous
et moi aussi quand j'ai vu les premières
images
mais ensuite quelque chose me dit qu'on
vous avez des problèmes ils ont déconné
mais non c'est pire que déconner c'est à
dire que quand on voit les cinq secondes
on se dit tout de suite mais ils ont
rien à faire dans la police et jean la
tête mais en plus on nous parle de
propos racistes sont rien à faire dans
la police et selon le premier rapport
au premier abord on veut être honnête on
veut pas qu'on sait que c'est notre
uniforme mais ensuite sûr qu'après vous
êtes dit je vais enquêter quand même
pour voir ce qui met déjà c'est incongru
c'est impossible enfin trois policiers
qui vont tabassé un mec pour rien juste
parce qu'il a pas de masque ils vont
traiter de sale [ __ ] mais j'ai 23 ans
de police j'ai 23 ans de police jamais
vu un truc pareil alors être sympa
d'être sympa cette affaire alors donnez
nous votre version ce soir et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé les images pour vous
était manipulé qu'est ce qui s'est passé
toute façon vous regardez le site leader
on parle de 20 minutes de tabassage pour
garder la minute il n'y a pas beaucoup
de travail à faire
12h20 vous regardez la vidéo il ya écrit
huit minutes parce qu'ils allaient la
totalité de la vidéo elle fait huit
minutes il ya deux vidéos attention
alors il y aura deux il ya une deuxième
vidéo qui fait quatre minutes 55 qui à
l'extérieur peu importe voilà a été
prise à l'extérieur il était menotté au
sol et il a pris une série de coups de
poing au visage alors qu'il était
menotté aux salles d'eau qui avait pas
de violence légitime à ce moment c'est
une super belle vue tu m'as pas des
biens la vidéo est disponible sur le net
il était menotté au sol il a été tabassé
il a pris une série de coups de poing au
visage par un policier âgé de 21 ans
plus précisément puisque j'ai eu j'ai
jeté un oeil au dossier et les images
démontrent clairement que il est 20
heures
voilà il y avait une vingtaine de
policiers autour qui n'ont absolument
pas à réécouter voilà c'est bien d'y
annoncer ma deuxième émission parce
qu'on fait justement la deuxième
émission sur la deuxième vidéo et il a
perdu en 7 6 0 il a perdu l'usagé de son
bras est il à 180 jours d'itt et et
quand on sait que la mesure légale
c'est-à-dire que le seuil légal qui
permet de caractériser un délit ou un
autre est fixé à 8 jours d'itt et et là
on est à 180 jours d'itt et et c'est à
dire plus de 20 fois
justement le lieu on va dire le seuil
qui est imposé par le code de procédure
pénale on se dit que c'est pas rien
c'est à dire on pas là on parle comme
s'il y avait quelque chose d'irrationnel
vous pouvez avoir un avis face à un
autre on a quand même un type là qui est
qui qui en situation de handicap à la
suite de cette intervention alors
justement bruno moi j'aimerais avoir
non mais on va tenir les policiers c'est
un vrai policier pardon mais oser pas
vrai policy sparrow si vous êtes un
magistrat le procès au tribunal vous
avez ce qu'il faut ce nom ici c'est pas
un crime
koné a déclaré j ai fini les excuses et
là c'est l abbé pierre qui était ici
mais là c'est alors look ça alors c'est
pas des vrais journalistes moi je suis
pas un vrai policier
toi t'es pas un vrai présentateur tout
est faux on arrête toi je veux dire là
laurent bruneau et donnez-nous votre
version wii mais je lui expliquais enfin
votre version de l'histoire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé les faits
alors qu'il fait 105 mes collègues qui
sont en train de contrôler ils sont
attirés à l'intérieur ils sont attirés à
l'intérieur donc c'est quoi alors ils
sont donc on veut on veut reprendre la
sphère dont on a eu la version de michel
loua brin la version de bordeaux bruno
donc pour vous donc michel d'éclairs
donc rentrer dans son studio
là il est interpellé pour un paravent
attendait alors déjà ce qu'il faut déjà
bien noter c'est que moi j'ai pas que
c'est la procédure d'accord toutes les
informations 100% des informations de
vue c'est sur le c sur internet alors
pas je me permets d'intervenir
oui parce que monsieur dit dans sa vidéo
présente moi j'ai regardé j'étais très
curieux de savoir quelles étaient les
faits nouveaux que je pouvais dont je
pouvais prendre connaissance d'excel
quelque chose d'une france nouvelle qui
est qui qui n'avait pas été mise à
disposition du public auparavant j'ai
pas trouvé
moi ce que monsieur affirme que les
policiers ont pas eu effectivement dans
la presse la possibilité de s'exprimer
c'est normal parce qu'ils ont été
incarcérés mais je pense qu'en france
aujourd'hui on incarcère pas les gens
comme ça dans toutes ces affaires qui
sont peints qui sont pas à décider de
les mettre en prison est aujourd'hui
sont sous contrôle judiciaire donc on
n'est pas dans une posture qui est
neutre alors que vous êtes ancien
fonctionnaire moyen aura des comme vous
et on se portera vouliez dessus ouais
c'est bien il faut vous faut devenir
ministre de l'intérieur avait cassé son
patient j'ai juste bruno patients s'ils
pensent que voilà je suis policier ma
carte est ici suspendu six mois pour
information oui vous vous êtes d'extrême
droite donc voilà donc si vous voulez on
colle des étiquettes seafrance police un
syndicat d'extrême droite comme ça on
s'est dit c'est incroyable mais voilà
de même pourquoi on dirait anciens
dernière jouait déjà avec ce que j'ai
demandé mon détachement sancourt bon
bref c'est pas le d'accord voilà non
mais pour la lecture compris que vous
êtes sur l'extrême droite c'est sujet du
rsa s'il vous plaît si oui mais non et
de là on va rester sur michel sur
l'interview dont on aimerait entendre
votre version à l'équilbre mais la
version à l'éclair j'ai trois policiers
qui sont dans une nasse sur la vidéo
regardez bien je demande à tout le monde
d'aller regarder sur touche pas à mon
flic on voit éclair qui bloque la porte
on voit éclair qui essaye de piquer
laquelle à la matraque de mes collègues
on voit éclair qui commet mais qui
bloque tout pourquoi il aurait fait ça
me touchait les acteurs à côté moi et
c'est quoi que c'était quoi son but il
ay là il a fait un guet-apens pour vous
non non non c'est pas un guet-apens
alors c'est qu'on écoute et il se
retrouve là pour moi il veut pas être
interpellé c'est une évidence
après moi je j'essaie de comprendre
pourquoi
oui je le dis dans ma vidéo j'ai dit
quoi pourquoi il fait ça
et donc j'ai cherché je me suis dit et
donc on a cherché ensuite on a regardé
qui a des trucs un peu bizarres
un mec qui met la main comme ça c'est
clair qu'ils regardaient dans sa
chaussette rigoureux et bufala bizarre
on peut finir avec vous alors le temps
et le temps est très court est ce que je
peux vous avec temps la wii alors en
fait ce dont sont accusées ces policiers
c'est effectivement les violences on va
pas revenir dessus à 180 jours d'itt et
et je suis pas juge effectivement je
sais c'est pas le nom de bob rae att qui
compte c est légitime à faux en écriture
c'est à dire qu'ils ont eu la parole
puisque les policiers ont la possibilité
de s'exprimer à travers des procès
verbaux ils sont assermentés nous c'est
à dire que leurs paroles ne peut pas en
théorie être remise en question serait
en effet la vidéo pour mes collègues ils
sont poursuivis 126 pour un crime parce
qu'il faut savoir que le faux en
écriture est poursuivi par le code de
procédure pénale commun qui sont les
minots sont au même niveau que le
meurtre ou le viol
donc on n'est pas sur une procédure
c'est un crime celle-ci géant cour
d'assises juste bruno j'aimerais que
vous terminiez à leur histoire
parce que là je vous jure que j'ai déjà
vu la vidéo là
les coups portés sont les comportés
monsieur mais moi j'aime bien tout ce
que d'abord expliqué on ne comprend rien
à ce que vous ayez histoire lardin
matériellement d'amour aimerait bruno
vraiment sans vous personne voilà le
personne n'intervienne guaino je réponds
dont vous nous expliquer du début à la
fin ce qui s'est passé et quelles
étaient les intentions de michel pauvres
pour moi michelle ne veut pas se faire
interpeller il ya une rébellion
caractérisé mes collègues restent
cependant dix minutes essayez de
l'interpeller et claire bloque la porte
pendant 10 minutes
ensuite il appelle ses amis en bas donc
mes collègues se retrouvent à 3 contre
10 mais vous avez vu la vidéo sais pas
ce qui s'est passé quoi rouler vous à la
fin arriver les collègues qui bloque la
porte et la procédure c'est donc de
tabac c'est quelqu'un à trois surfaces à
la procédure compte en effet prendre
votre matelas c'est bien jolie madame
commandant comment vos photos votre
canapé de dire comment il faut quand il
faut j'ai fort on pose une question
réponse et dire vous parliez de
procédures je vous explique en gros je
vous explique les violences policières
elles sont soit légitime soit illégitime
si vous estimez pas ce que vous vous
regardez ses seconds là où effectivement
il vient de fermer la porte et il s'est
calé les jeunes qui montent
il lui porte des coups mais c est ce que
ces coûts sont légitimes ou illégitimes
c'est ça vous devez vous poser comme
question sait pas combien dit été ça va
ça ça a fait vous comprenez c'est à dire
est-ce que c'est légitime pour vous ces
coûts étaient légitimes pourquoi mais
est ce que vous dites qu'il essayait de
la traque de son bloqué non non la
matraque c'est après les attirer il les
a bloqués mais c'est n'importe quoi il
est tout seul il en train de se faire
tabasser et oui on était en être à nous
expliquer que c'est lui qui les a
attirés et qu'il est en train de les
bloquer à l'intérieur non mais là
l'élection fut désolé ce qui est dommage
c'est que je pensais qu'on allait
regarder la vidéo
si on va regarder la première vidéo
comme ça on va les voir alors déjà vous
accusez notamment donc vous dites qu'ils
ont accéléré les images pour renforcer
le côté violent de la scène
regardez on va voir les trois
manipulations que là on voit mon
collègue tenir est clair pour l'empêcher
de recul et spécialités de l'outsider
accélération de la vidéo pour donner une
impression de violence à la scène alors
que les policiers m'ont pour l'instant
porté aucun cours et tente de faire
sortir éclair en utilisant la force
strictement nécessaire
premier coup de pied du policier sur le
tibet est clair pour tenter de le faire
sortir et claire réussi à refermer la
porte c'est clair ouvre la porte du sous
sol sachant qu'ils viennent de familles
en bas on devine qui les appelle ils se
retrouvent enfermés dans trois mètres
carrés et l'individu a réussi à appeler
des renforts stress peur énervement
voilà les images qui vont être reprises
en boucle quatre coups avec la main
droite du premier policier trois coups
de poing de l'autre policier
c'était la partie la plus violente qui
aura duré 11 secondes
alors ça c'est première vidéo on va voir
la deuxième vidéo pour vous bruno ya une
image qui prouve aussi que michel aurait
tenté de s'emparer de la matraque d'un
des policiers
regardez les amis deux éclairs pousse la
porte du sous sol
les policiers sont pris au piège c'est
clair bloque toujours la porte un
policier sort sa matraque télescopique
plus le choix on doit sortir le policier
hésite puis fait le choix de ne pas
porter de coups avec sa matraque sur est
clair cette décision prise en une demi
seconde permettra un éclair de tenter de
dérober cette arme
l'autre policier se jette sur est clair
pour le maîtriser ils ne peuvent pas se
permettre de laisser éclair avec cette
arme qui en a parlé
qui a parlé de cette situation est
claire lâche la matraque et se jette sur
la porte pour empêcher le policier de
sortir il pousse à nouveau la porte
violemment avec sa main puis l'a bloqué
avec son pied et tente encore de prendre
la matraque alors il ya la grenade qui a
été jeté à l'intérieur
moi j'y suis allé j'ai vu la brûlure la
moquette qui était brûlée etc
c'est visible sur la vidéo et cela c'est
occulter ce ya aucun règlement de police
qui autorise justement ce qu'on puisse
faire usage de ce type de grenade dans
un local fermé à l'intérieur ça peut
même être létales on ne sait pas si
michel est asthmatique
s'il ya d'autres personnes parmi les
neuf jeunes qui pourraient être
vulnérables
donc il ya cette dimension qui occultait
justement dans le commentaire et l'igpn
mais également les magistrats ont
reconnu que c'était interdit
moi je comprends même pas la nature de
ce débat c'est à dire que là on est en
train de faire quelque chose on est en
train d' occulter
j'irai complètement la dimension la
vraie justice je dire que je veux bien
qu'on débatte qu'on fasse jacon qu'on
fasse une mise en scène qui justice
populaire je veux dire c'est intéressant
de donner son avis il ya une vraie
justice qui fonctionne bien la preuve
c'est qu'ils hier on a un président de
la république qui a été condamnée ce qui
prouve bien que la justice finalement
n'épargne personne policiers ou pas
président de la république ou pas tout
le monde en france est jugé selon
justement les mêmes discours alors il ya
une autre accusation met en place une
justice a expliqué que c'est michel
leblanc les images que nous monde bruno
il ya aussi vous avez l'impression que
michel directrice c'est bien de
rencontrer images qui parlent on peut
dire que vous allez parler mais j'ai dit
clairement et tenté de dissimuler
quelque chose de regarder après vous
savez on dit petit à petit manoir
alors il semble s'adresser aux deux
jeunes face à lui celui avec la capuche
rouge lève la tête et regarde la caméra
comme si on prévenait qu'il était filmé
il semble retirer quelque chose de sa
chaussure ou de sa chaussette qui serait
peut-être tombé à terre bizarrement le
jeûne avec ta capuche rouge ça soit une
demi-seconde sans aucune raison puis se
relève aussitôt c'est clair et toujours
dos tourné à cette caméra et qu'est ce
que fait le jeune qui se relève aussitôt
on voit le jeune avec la capuche
regarder la caméra
le jeune à gauche ouvre sa main droite
comme s'il attendait qu'on lui donne
quelque chose
alors quelle est leur apparaît comme
ayant mais s'il vous plaît laissez
parler c'est ça qui me pose est pourquoi
alors beaux éclairs ne se laisse pas
interpellé donc moi j'ai éliminé et
minuit une hypothèse avec ces choses qui
sont un peu bizarre pourquoi est
clairsemé doigt la caméra pourquoi et
sans on voit se toucher la chaussette
pourquoi il ya un gamin qui lui fait ça
et parfois l'autre et regarde donc voilà
ça c'est une hypothèse
maintenant c'est exactement ce que vaut
donc votre version il parlait
franchement c'est quoi votre version
même la version tout simplement
oui mais c'est quoi c'est michel hector
adéquat quelque chose est licite
donc quoi baladera vous dites la vérité
m'a dit que non mais attendez mais bien
sûr mais bon on sait très bien que
c'était du cannabis en la retraite du
cannabis j'ai oublié de dire quand il
était assis ici alors on m'a dit tu le
dit ou alors c'est quoi l'histoire
non mais dans la première nation hôte et
nous l'histoire je le dis dans la
compétition on a retrouvé le cannabis
pourquoi tu n'es pas parler quand il
était là alors pourquoi pas chez vous la
normale
j'avais pas cet élément mais on n'en
avait pas on m'a dit que c'était une
rumeur je lis énormément alors donc
c'est quoi l'histoire m'a dit on pas en
france il ya des lois
je dire on ne peut pas entrer chez les
gens ils avaient domiciles privés sont
d'accord on peut pas résoudre nos sens
les policiers n'ont pas le droit de
s'introduire dans un domicile privé à
chaque le ce qui lui étaient reprochés
s'étaient acheté une part il c'était une
infraction et contraventionnelle pense
qu'il n'autorise pas les policiers à
pénétrer dans son domicile aux états et
donc légal
j'aimerais tourner je veux dire oh non
c'est pas ça vous comprenez le métier de
policier mais moi je suis un vrai
policier
vous savez pas que quand vous êtes
enfermé et que vous avez dit gars qui
sont autour de vous effectivement quand
vous portez vous n'avez pas le droit
mais derrière c'est difficile ça veut
dire non mais c'est quoi vraiment j ai
fait tout c'est même pas qu'on n'a pas
le droit d'entrer chez les gens finiront
peut sans motif ni cgc simplement
pourquoi est il si on rentrait chez lui
près son entraîneur mais ils étaient en
cours d'interpellation d'accord d'accord
ensuite si vous regardez bien c'est une
ancienne boutique ça peut être un
établissement recevant du public
on ne sait pas quand n'a pas accès à la
procédure d'accord on peut supputer sur
sur certains trucs
ce qu'il faut regarder c'est les
certitudes les certitudes c'est quoi
vous allez poser une super question ça a
été la meilleure question c'est les
violences à ce qu'elles sont légitimes
ou illégitimes
quand vous voyez ces coups là bien sûr
que c'est violent oui bien sûr que c'est
violent quand mais est-ce qu'il était
utile est-ce qu'ils étaient strictement
nécessaire quand vous savez qu'il vient
juste à l'instant d'appeler 9 mai qui
sont en bas mais vous avez déjà vécu
cette situation
vous avez déjà vécu et ça c'est quoi ce
au fond du canapé canton mais moi
j'aurais fait ça et moi j'aurais fait ça
mais oui l'apavi cubisme un vrai
policier c'est pas un vrai projet bien
sûr un véhicule le président de la
république est un menteur le ministre de
l'intérieur aussi le journaliste de
l'outsider et serena tata et le copain
michel internationale c'est finalement
michel est méchant c'est une atteinte à
la présomption d'innocence
vous savez qui sont saluées l'a
officiellement ils sont ils sont
innocents mes collègues avaient parlé
ils ont pu traitement ils ont été
traités comme des chiens ils ont des
gamins qui ont chialé qui ont regardé
votre émission kankan est clair il était
là et que vous disiez que tu comment que
que ce que ses parents étaient des
racistes oui mais voulez vous dites on
n'a jamais dit ça bien sûr messi a bola
ça oui la vidéo oui oui oui alors je
vais vous dire il ya un moment mais non
je m'y attendais attendez jamais dit ça
va presque toutes vos émissions que je
peux vous dire que selon les échos font
là-bas
oui mais ça que j'avais dit non mais
attendez exactement ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'il avait écrit sale [ __ ] en
gros ici d'accord encore une fois si mes
collègues avait ne serait-ce que une
once de racisme je défendrai jamais mes
chagrins
mais quand il y avait écrit sale [ __ ]
voilà c'est écrit comme ça sale [ __ ]
qui avait une demoiselle blonde comme ça
qu'ils disent est grave c'est très grave
le souci c'est la vérité bien sûr que
c'est très bien évidemment c'est ça la
vérité bah oui mais elle est soudain
elle sous-entendait que comme c'était
écrit elle sous-entendait que c'était
vrai à dire regardez c'est vrai c'est
écrit écrit sale [ __ ]
s'il vous plaît elle se fie aux images
nous ont regardé les images juste je
sais pas si vous l'avez vu ici dans
cette émission et je pense que deux
hommes connais bien mes émissions ici on
n'est pas anti flics ça n'a jamais une
sur vingt dix pour cent des flics
étaient des bons mecs savent bien que
10% son nom 95 maintenant toutes les
îles alors 90 % ça veut dire quoi en
télé c'est pareil 90% dans une vie à
tous les métiers
quinze vingt mille policiers gendarmes
qui sont des crapules et réussit pas
mais le voit quand et n'importe quoi
mais vous raconter ça c'est le vôtre
c'est une femme à n'importe quoi parlez
vous dites vous dit des bêtises
non je n'ai pas décidé ce jeudi bien des
bêtises vous n'ayez pas à blâmer pour ça
c'est de 10% et en plus élitiste et des
baux il y avait des brebis galeuses et
écoute
les pieds ici en fonction qu'ils l'ont
dit dans cette émission j'ai pas le chic
vous l'avez vous le 6 mai pour ça que je
pense pas que c'est parce que j'ai pas
dessus de chiffres alors voilà alors ses
lunettes 99 chez les policiers
évidemment les métiers alors mais en
fait je comprends le monsieur dans sa
vidéo dit qu'effectivement il est dans
le camp de la vérité donc le pauvre on
ne peut pas je dis je vais pas le
contredire
moi je pense pas qu'il faille adopter
cette posture baer qui a été initié au
début par le préfet de police qui dit
qu'il ya deux camps moi je pense que la
population française en fait c'est un
seul camp et que la police et 1,6 à lui
comme les autres bien sûr identifié qui
sont alors quand on est dans un syndicat
alors vous êtes notionnels dire aux
douaniers les émissions parce que là
vous commencez à m'énerver à dire des
bêtises mais voilà on a toujours pris la
défense de la police et des bêtises vous
retournez dans ce média codé
des tribunes à des centaines de
policiers la notion des policiers
syndicalistes n'ont jamais vu un
uniforme faut travailler et sont venus
ont une histoire et si oui alors mais
bah oui je vous le dis c'est que son
uniforme c'est pas le procès de deux
émissions dans des propositions va
recentrer ici parce que c'est
intéressant ce qui promet mais ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que les syndicats
de police sont des syndicats
professionnels comme les autres mais il
ya quand même une particularité c'est
que quand on doit choisir entre la
solidarité et la justice
on doit faire passer la justice avant la
solidarité moi je suis solidaire de
l'ensemble de mes collègues quand je
suis bien leur travail bien sûr mais
jamais au mépris de la justice
la justice doit toujours passer avant la
solidarité et la justice ne s'est pas
prononcé pis il ya quand même un type
qui a perdu l'usagé d'un bras de rien
n'était vous avez marqué ici l'agression
deux éclairs monsieur hanouna c'est
l'agression présumée il a perdu un bras
sont prêts je dirais la période face à
julia non monsieur j'ai une question à
vous poser avec les si on a toujours
respecté sur la déontologie policière
il ya plein de policiers qui sont venus
de syndicats moi je connais bien
extrêmement représentatif d'accord moi
j'ai une question à vous poser point la
déontologie policière c'est un usage
proportionné de la force
j'ai lu j'ai entendu tout ce que vous
avez fait est ce que vous estimez que
les coûts qui ont été portées à monsieur
est clair qu'ils sont en usage
proportionné de la force par les
policiers
c'est une bonne question oui ou non sur
ces coups là sur ces coups-là répondait
monsieur en avez vous mais c'est ça que
vous pensez que cette science exacte la
violence adacore d'un moyen de vos
arguments et que les gars ne suis pas
d'accord c'est que vous
misez la violence avec un argument de
temps cerveau dit ça n'a pas duré onze
minutes ça a duré une minute 11 secondes
6 rue de la violence abusive la violence
abusive mais c'est dur et 11 minutes et
mon autre question c'est vous fait plein
de sous-entendus
vous dites qu'il aurait eu la drogue etc
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils auraient
séquestré les policiers selon vous
quelles étaient ses intentions
bah tout simplement gagner du temps et
des ses amis montée pour ensuite pour
pouvoir expliquer les policiers et
ensuite pouvoir faire autre chose tout
simplement expulsé mais mehdi qui met
les frapper non il expulser les
policiers non armés pour les expulser
donc tâcher de là prétend il attend ses
amis qui viennent lui donner un coup de
main pour qu'ensuite les policiers bien
et c'est ce qui est arrivé d'ailleurs
pourquoi il faut les expulser si c'est
lui qui les a enfermés non il les a
enfermés mais oui les enfermer non mais
on arrive à les expulser
mais quand les neuf sont montés après
les 9 mai mais c'est ce qui est arrivé
c'est à dire vous avez vu les images
vous dites il a fermé la porte pour les
faire venir à l'intérieur et ensuite ils
veulent les expulser qu'est ce qu'il
veut faire entre temps lui il est à
l'intérieur avec les policiers d'accord
ensuite eagle seagull il appelle ses
amis ambre embarque pour ses amis
montent et ensuite quand ses amis
montent ils vont se retrouver à 10
contre 3 mais ensuite là il pourra les
dégager mais puisqu'il les a fait venir
ça que je comprends pas alors qu'à venir
moi je suis extrêmement gênés en fait
parce que vous dites parce que
effectivement il peut y avoir de vérité
celle de la victime
bien sûr la police mais c'est pour ça
que mon absence que tout à l'heure vous
faites des sous-entendus et je ne
comprends rien c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné il ya quand même eu une
réinterprétation d'une vidéo avec entre
autres un échange mais fait un échange
alors concrètement c'est quoi soyons
factuel ces deux-là droit mais moi je
vous dise excusez moi c'est le terrain
moi ce que j'entends c'est michel éclair
en fait on alors j'ai toujours pas
compris l'histoire de me rentrer il sort
mais ça ne s'est pas compris on s'en
fout nord en réalité michel éclair est
un trafiquant de drogue qui avait de la
drogue sur lui la ilaha illa tu es
méchant mais dans les deux cas alors
vous appelez ça comment abandonner
qu'est-ce-qui
ils ont sur un truc et les
téléspectateurs 10 pareil sur les
réseaux sociaux il se doit avant qu'on
clôture sur cette affaire et sur votre
témoignage
j'aimerais qu'on nous dit si un début un
milieu une fin qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pour vous voilà comme ça pourrait pas
dire que je vous ai pas de laisser la
parole khalid contrôle de police alors
donc mais on reprend michel d'éclairer
dans la rue il se passe quoi contrôle de
police d'accord il a pas de masque ils
sentent une odeur de cannabis
d'accord il le contrôle avec sert de la
rue c'est clair recul
le collègue rentrer avec lui on sait pas
qui pousse qui tirent les trois autres
arrivent et c'est de le sortir pour
l'interpeller parce qu'ils sont à
l'interpellation d'accord et oui donc
alors qu'ils restent dans la rue parce
qu'il voulait pas rentrer maintenant il
le tire il le tire de loin il on
l'interpellé faufiler sur lui a tant
qu'il le tir ensuite éclair referme la
porte et les se retrouve enfermé avec
lui et lui fait 110 kg il se met en
boule
donc c'est très compliqué et l'envoie
ils n'ont porté aucun coup à ce moment
là donc ils essayent c'est de l'attrapé
ils essayent essai de l'interpeller donc
ils n'y arrivent pas ils n'y arrivent
pas ensuite c'est clair arrive à ouvrir
la porte et il appelle ses amis peut
comprendre qu'on prenne à mon avis
encore une fois de suite que il ya neuf
familles en bas qui est mon arrivée il
voit les premiers pour commence moi je
pense que le collègue entend les neuf
jade montée est donc là il arrive et il
porte des fous maintenant si vous portez
des coûts pour comment comment juste
pour commander violences policières
illégitimes mais là est ce que c'est le
cas est-ce que c'est légitime ou pas
star ils veulent l'interpeller
ils veulent le le bloqué ils veulent
donc ils se retrouvent avec lui ensuite
il ya le policier qui bloque la porte
qui bloque la porte c'est quoi alors d
abbas qu'il avait il avait deux là il
avait de la drogue sur l'iss
c'est une hypothèse c'est une fois non
mais d'abord il avait de la drogue
puisque c'est qu'ils ont on a retrouvé
du cannabis d'accord
une hypothèse non non ça c'est pas une
hypothèse et on attend la réponse des
concertos et du talent un trafiquant oui
pardon consommateurs c'est pas trafiqué
moi c'est une contravention et nicolas
sur la première semaine passée c'est un
pour le cannabis est une contravention
non mais non non ça tu es content c'est
ça a changé d'avoir changé quelques mois
c'est plus un délit c'est une
contravention s'il est pas récidiviste
en plus claire des multirécidivistes
parce que l'arrière de la prison
terminé donc bruno donc demain donc du
coup mes collègues se trouve enfermé
avec lui le collet de la lui porte des
coups il entend du monde car il y laisse
à mon avis de le sécher de dire voilà
maintenant il faut de sécher c'est de la
violence oui mais nous l'avions c'est
notre quotidien
donc il faut sécher le mec il faut
pouvoir l'interpeller il faut pouvoir le
neutraliser pour ensuite le sortirai
l'exfiltrer c'est une d'intervention
police qui me semble plutôt classique
bien sécher le saigner plutôt oui
nicolas jamais alors moi j'ai une
question ultra importante et vous avez
mis le doigt dessus
quel est l'intérêt d'arrêter quelqu'un à
l'extérieur ou à l'intérieur est ce
qu'il ya une grande différence mais ce
que vous êtes en train de dire que peut
être je lui ramène la police à
l'intérieur donc peut-être que ça n'est
pas la même chose
we believe que la police garés à
l'extérieur alors ils avaient ils
n'avaient pas le droit de pénétrer ça a
été établie d'ailleurs car bond de 16
qui est quand même tout par l'éminent
qui a fait le commentaire de cet énorme
elle explique c'est ce qu' il était dans
l'illégalité
non mais en fait c'est le magistrat qui
me dit ils ont été incarcérés à dire
quand on l'écouté des bizounours
l'équipe j'aimerais dire oui à 39% non à
61% mais il ya 39 % des gens qui pensent
comme vous bruno en tout cas bruno vous
avez regardé c'est qu'il ya 39 % mais je
pense qu'il ya bien 90% des policiers
mais je demande à tous mes collègues
policiers
comment de nous soutenir en demandant
leur syndicat de nous soutenir
et si le syndicat ne nous soutiennent
pas qu'ils déchirent leur carte et qui
est qu'ils apportent leur soutien à nos
collègues qui sont partis en prison des
pères de famille ici on a reçu une
personne sans combat sans ce sans débat
contradictoire mais il faut l'avouer on
à votre version aujourd'hui si l'on fait
avant vous auriez été en phase ii
messieurs
je voyais sereinement je demande aux
collectes de laisser la justice
travailler sereinement n'écoutez pas ce
genre de baliseurs sénat compte devoir
me lever l'injustice ni fonctionne
convenablement
c'est quoi ce délire de déchirer des
cartes d'essayer de faire pression sur
la justice
un contrat pendant ces sept faire
pression sur les syndicats qui ne
défendent pas nos collègues mais il ya
une affaire de justice en cours
celanese madame appareils d'immenses
exemplaire de syndicalistes et autres
justice met pas la pression sur la
justice
est ce que est ce que nos syndicats vont
se prononcer est ce que les autres
syndicats et jérôme alliance mais
messieurs à se prononcer est ce qu'ils
sont pour cette version est ce qu'ils
connaissent le métier de policier
ou alors est ce qu'ils disent banon
finalement c'est clair est une victime
l'exposition tous mes collègues
attendent ça tous les connais tous les
policiers de france
ils vivent ça à mes collègues et moi je
me suis retrouvé dans ce genre de
situation je me suis retrouvé dans ce
genre de situation mon fils mais vous
avez envoyé des gens en prison parce
qu'à l'époque caméra ce qui serait
arrivé s'il n'y avait pas eu la caméra
où vous avez l'habitude de la violence
j'avais raison quand vous voyez ça fait
avec la tabasser ça saigne
est-ce que c'est pas l'habitude de la
violence vous à vous et n'hésitez pas à
sarcelles vous savez vous savez pas
l'habitude ces données c'est celle-là ça
vous choque vous mais ce qui veut dire
vous n'êtes pas habituel a eu donc
forcément les gens sachent qu'ils ont
des gens très bien je veux dire arrêter
avec cette ville aussi comme une farce
est non mais moi j'ai grandi à
goussainville juste poussé des gens très
bien aux plays